[Applause]
I were on a show I know it's exciting
but throwie gets all that I just have to
say you know what I play Texas a lot
spent a lot of time down there I love it
down there so they're having a hurricane
so our thoughts are with them hurricane
Harvey's already wreaked a lot of havoc
there Trump came out with a very strong
statement condemning the violence on
both sides
now this is this is Trump's first
natural disaster the others they all
cost himself and he has a message for
the people of Texas in their time of
need he stands ready to tweet if he gets
any shitty coverage of it and that FEMA
is standing by to provide bottles of
Trump water and only slightly higher
than retail price isn't a very good deal
a very good deal and speaking of very
good deals it looks like it looks like
this week did you see the to Trump's
thing that they're all talking about you
know general Kelley took over as the
chief of staff a couple of weeks ago it
looks like he made a deal with general
Kelley that on Monday Wednesday and
Friday I will be I will be teleprompter
Trump and the other days I'll be able to
free free to tweet crazy batshit and
shout [ __ ] at rednecks and airplane
hangars
so Monday teleprompter Trump made a
foreign policy speech that was very
normal and reassuring and then the next
day he went to Arizona for a rebuttal
a rebuttal to himself that's the world
were living and he was actually bragging
about it he tweeted the other day too
bad for the Dems they have no one who
can change tones
yeah it's called schizophrenia [ __ ]
it has gotten so bad that this week the
tabloids were describing a Shia
LaBeouf's behavior as erratic bordering
on presidential it is at the point where
when he is merely hypocritical it is
reassuring I mean for years he never
stopped tweeting about how we had to get
out of Afghanistan get out of Adam I'm
stupid Obama was to be their stupid
Obama
well now we're staying turns out if you
like your endless war in Afghanistan you
can keep your endless war in Afghanistan
and you know this war has been going on
for 16 years 16 years Republicans I got
to say they they do like their war wives
come and go but war they're willing to
work at so that was Monday the big
Afghan speech and then Tuesday the big
rally in Phoenix the fans loved it
Infowars gave it four and a half
straitjackets
and Trump was in rare form he was
blasting the fake news media for how
they misrepresented his response to
Charlotte ville right and and and hey
you know when people are unfairly saying
you like Nazis what better way to dispel
that notion than to host a hate rally in
Arizona with all white people oh yeah
people keep calling me a [ __ ] I'll show
them I'm going to the Roadhouse and [ __ ]
all the bikers
and and I tell you I give it to his
friends they do love him it was hot in
feels like 107 it was so hot his fans
were chanting Jews please replace it
that guy I guess no but here's my little
wisp of hope for this week at the rally
this is the first time I've seen this
his fans they got bored and started to
leave early maybe the magic spell is
wearing off so sick of hearing the same
old [ __ ] the news is fake foreigners are
taking your jobs I'm being treated
unfairly by the time he gets to build
the wall people are like you know if we
leave during draining the swamp we can
beat the traffic I mean when he finally
started in on Hillary they were like
wrap it up
[Applause]